Solche waghalsigen Kampfszenen
machen einen Bond-Film
zum Traum einer jeden Stuntfrau.
Dass ich das noch mal mitnehmen durfte
als Hauptdouble von der Hauptdarstellerin
und acht Monate diesen Film gedreht hab‘,
war 'ne ganz, ganz tolle Erfahrung.
Die Berlinerin Marie Mouroum doubelt die
britische Schauspielerin Lashana Lynch –
die erste schwarze Doppel-Null-Agentin
im 25. Bond-Abenteuer
„Keine Zeit zu sterben“.
Dieser James-Bond-Film beweist,
dass Frauen eben genauso
Actionhelden sein können wie 007.
Action-Szenen wie diese zählen zu dem Stoff,
aus dem Filme gemacht sind.
Die Deutsche Marie Mouroum besiegt
den Feind auf der großen Leinwand –
als Stunt-Double für Hollywoods
größte Heldinnen.
Ich hab‘ verschiedenste Filme gedreht
auf der ganzen Welt verteilt,
wie zum Beispiel „Black Panther“,
„Avengers Infinity War“, „Avengers Endgame“,
der neueste „James Bond“.
Aktuell dreht Marie Mouroum
mehrere Monate einen Film in New York –
wieder ein actionreiches Abenteuer.
Der Weg bis zum heutigen Erfolg war
kein leichter als schwarze Frau.
Geboren und aufgewachsen
ist die 29-Jährige in Berlin.
Für meine Mutter war es immer wichtig,
dass wir uns verteidigen können,
ich und mein Bruder.
Weil wir in Ost-Berlin,
in Berlin-Friedrichshain, groß geworden sind,
zu 'ner Zeit, wo es schon relativ gefährlich
war für uns schwarze Kinder auf der Straße,
sag ich mal, und wir oft Situationen hatten,
die ein bisschen gefährlicher waren.
Und so beginnt die kleine Marie
mit dem Kampfsporttraining.
Mit 14 gewinnt sie zum ersten Mal
internationale Wettbewerbe.
Um sich für die anspruchsvollen Einsätze fit
zu halten, muss sie täglich trainieren.
Für den Job als Stuntfrau braucht man zwar
keine Lizenz, aber eine starke Kondition.
Dafür zahlt sie einen hohen Preis.
Bei der Arbeit als Stuntfrau ist es
natürlich auch nicht unüblich,
dass man sich verletzen kann.
Die Verletzungsgefahr ist auch groß,
auch wenn sie es nicht sein sollte.
Viele Sachen sind super geplant,
und trotzdem kann man sich verletzen.
Dessen sollte man sich bewusst sein.
Also, ich hab‘ mir schon öfter
kleinere Verletzungen zugefügt,
aber ich hatte auch schon
etwas größere Verletzungen.
Ich hab‘ mir mal den Meniskus angerissen
oder den Fuß gebrochen und solche Sachen.
Aber die heilen dann und dann geht’s weiter.
Marie Mouroums Start in der Filmindustrie
war nicht leicht.
Lange Zeit waren Action-Helden
ausschließlich männlich und weiß,
und die meisten Stunts
– selbst für weibliche Rollen –
wurden von Männern übernommen.
Es war schwer für mich, Jobs zu kriegen
als Frau und dann noch als schwarze Frau.
Das war so doppelt blöd
eigentlich in dem Moment.
Und dann war ich auch an so einem Punkt,
wo ich auch verzweifelt war und dachte:
Ey, ich weiß nicht, wie das weitergeht
und ob das für mich auch
überhaupt ‘ne Zukunft hat.
Ihren Durchbruch erlebt sie 2018 als Double
in einem Hollywood-Action-Blockbuster.
Seit „Black Panther“ ist es weltweit…
hat sich das Filmbild verändert. Weltweit.
Auf einmal ist in jedem Film…
sind auf jeden Fall schwarze Leute
repräsentiert, viele starke schwarze Rollen.
Für all diese Rollen steht Marie Mouroum
als Stuntfrau bereit.
Momentan ist es so,
dass ich extrem stolz auf mich selbst bin
und manchmal echt mich so erwische,
wie ich gar nicht fassen kann,
was ich gerade für ein Leben führe.
Also genau das,
was ich mir über die Jahre aufgebaut habe,
was ich mir immer gewünscht hab‘.
Und zugleich ebnet sie den Weg
für weitere Frauen,
die ihrem Beispiel nun folgen können.